foreign
[Music]
it's ten o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
the press secretary to the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex describes the moment
the couple were pursued by Paparazzi in
New York after they said they were
involved in a near catastrophic car
chase I would find it hard to believe
that there was a two-hour high-speed
chase but if it's 10 minutes or 10
minute Chase is extremely dangerous in
New York City
also tonight the founder of the
collapsed company British Vault tells
Sky News Britain has lost its
opportunity for a battery industry and
says the prime minister is to blame you
already are behind East Asia you're
already behind Continental Europe
UK unfortunately has lost out or is
losing out
heavy rainfall and deadly floods hit
Italy as climate scientists warned that
the global temperature will likely reach
1.5 degrees of warming by 2027.
one baby formula manufacturer admits the
industry needs to do more after Sky News
revealed desperate families were
stealing to feed infants
the government unveils its renting
reforms including a ban on no fault
evictions critics say it will drive
landlords out of the sector
and Manchester City on track to win the
champions league for the first time
making it through to the final after a
4-0 win over Real Madrid
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from hot Boston
foreign
[Music]
good evening the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex have long had a strange
relationship with the press and now they
say that they were pursued for two hours
by Paparazzi in a near catastrophic car
chase in New York City seeking help from
local police even switching cars to
evade the cameras well the New York
Police Department says that the
situation which happened following an
event last night was challenging but
there were no reported collisions
injuries or arrests our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone reports now
from New York a warning his report
contains flush
photography throughout
[Music]
the couple had left the Manhattan awards
ceremony at just before 10 pm
the flashes and the clicks an indication
of the intense focus on them even at
this side door from the venue
with their own private security they
left with Megan's mother in a black 4x4
no police escort and that they say is
when the pursuit began from here they'd
plan to Drive North to stay at a
friend's house on the Upper East Side
but they say they were chased in what
they called a Relentless Pursuit that
were near misses with other cars with
pedestrians and with two police officers
the spokesman for the couple has said to
me that 12 photographers were chasing
them and that it left them in her words
incredibly scared and shaken up
the couple's public statement said it
was a near-catastrophic car chase at the
hands of a ring of Highly aggressive
paparazzi
while being a public figure comes with a
level of interest from the public it
should never come at the cost of
anyone's safety dissemination of these
images given the way in which they were
obtained encourages a highly intrusive
practice that is dangerous to all
involved
it was dark when they drove through the
streets a few routes were made in an
attempt to lose the tail the couple did
not want their destination their
friend's home to be revealed
three times they came to this police
station in an attempt to lose the
photographers at one stage they left in
a Yellow Cab and we've seen the
paparazzi images from that taxi Prince
Harry filming them as they snapped him
well they look nervous I mean I think
they were being chased the whole day or
something so they were pretty nervous
you know but the security guard he was
on it and what did you think about the
description of this you know the near
catastrophic event oh I don't think
that's true I think that's all you know
exact related and stuff at around 10 pm
Harry and Megan left the Ziegfeld
ballroom with private security heading
towards where they were staying on the
Upper East Side
they were then driven across 57th Street
up and down FDR Drive and other streets
for about an hour and 15 minutes Sky
News understands the couple entered the
19th Precinct Police Station three times
on the third occasion they stayed for
about 15 minutes police helped them into
a different car and then on to their
residence on the Upper East Side without
being followed
the city's mayor described it all as
Reckless and irresponsible but he
counted any suggestion of a high-speed
Pursuit I would find it hard to believe
that there was a two-hour high-speed
chase that would be I find it hard to
believe but we will find out the exact
duration of it but if it's uh 10 minutes
a 10-minute Chase is extremely dangerous
in New York City the New York Police
Department characterized it not as a
Chase but did say they were being
followed it's clear though that the
couple see direct parallels with Paris
August 1997 and the chase which killed
Harry's mother and shifted the course of
his life
my biggest concern was history repeating
itself and I've said that before
on numerous occasions very publicly we
know from his book and the Netflix
series that he is used to Pursuit but
the sussexes claimed that this was of a
different order and comes as the prince
heads into An Almighty Court battle with
the British press over privacy Mark
Stone Sky News in New York
now from New York also with us tonight
is our Royal correspondent Laura bundock
Mark to you first there seems to be some
uh variance in the accounts as to what
actually happened you've been speaking
though to an Insider close to the couple
yes I had 15 minutes on the phone a
couple of hours ago with uh the sussex's
spokesperson who has been with them in
New York today and it was very
interesting it gave a clear account from
their point of view of what happened uh
clearly they are aware that there is
some dispute over this idea of a of a
two-hour high-speed chase what she was
clear uh to me was that um there were
moments when this was a stationary uh
pursuit in the sense that they were not
driving at speed for two hours around
New York uh City but there were moments
where they needed to drive very fast
there were moments where they were
stationary where their security one of
whom used to work for the U.S president
uh and uh indeed for the Metropolitan
Police got out of the car and tried to
reason with the photographers before the
pursuit then took place again um she she
gave us the spokesperson gave us a
statement so I'll read it to you she
says I have never experienced their
vulnerability as much as I did last
night they were incredibly scared and
shaken up there were several times where
they where the car stopped and security
got out there were instances where the
police confronted the paparazzi and uh
and asked them to stop or give them
space to do this safely unfortunately
that wish was not respected
um so that they're a statement from the
press secretary for the sussexes um they
are well aware that there will be many
that see this simply as a a publicity
stunt by The sussexes Who are in the
middle of this uh very heated Court
battle uh in the UK they counter that
strongly they say simply that it was
quite clear last night here on the
streets of New York that their safety
was in danger but not only their safety
the safety of pedestrians and other
drivers here around New York City
all right Mark thank you let's uh bring
in our Royal correspondents Laura
bundock now
um Laura this would be presumably the
circumstances of this deeply uh
distressing animotive particularly for
Prince Harry and will only add to what's
already a very strange relationship with
the Press
yeah I think it's clear from that
statement just how frightening everyone
involved found this but for Harry Not
only was he alarmed but he is angry
about this as well he knows that when he
steps out in public especially with
Megan their first public outing since
the coronation there'll be a lot of
media interest he didn't expect this
though he is of course someone who has
grown up without her mother she was
killed in a car crash while being chased
by the paparazzi his dislike of the
media is well documented Mark was saying
in the Netflix series his Memoir a spare
in the subsequent interviews he gave he
blames the paparazzi for dialer's death
and wants to do everything he can to
protect his own family to stop history
repeating itself those were his words it
is worth pointing out though that we
have only had the extreme details from
the sussexes their statements give a lot
more gave a lot more detail than that of
the police and of course cynics are
saying Harry has a lot of ongoing legal
cases both against the press and the
people who decided to take away his
personal security but I think if you
take a step back this shows us just how
low Harry has set his personal bar when
it comes to how he deals with what he
deems to be
um unwanted and intrusive media Behavior
thank you very much
now the founder of the Giga Factory
company British Vault has told Sky News
that Britain has missed the opportunity
to build a battery industry and that the
government is to blame in an exclusive
interview or al-najari said that we are
already behind Asia and Europe it comes
after warnings of further strains on the
UK's car industry as our economics and
data editor Ed Conway reports
the British Vault gigafactory was
supposed to be the UK's first homegrown
battery plant a leveling up success
story fueled by public money but when it
collapsed into Administration earlier
this year the dream heralded by
government ministers was left in tatters
now in his first interview since the
implosion British vault's founder has
told Sky News that the government must
take much of the blame when you think of
what might have been do you feel sad do
you feel angry devastated we already
are behind East Asia we're already
behind Continental Europe
UK unfortunately has lost out or is
losing out on the gigafactory economy
which is massive in terms of job
creation but unfortunately didn't see
that same support
from the conservative government in
order to level up the Northeast you
didn't get the support that you felt you
should have got definitely not
at least not from a timing perspective
it was a major rivalry going on between
Mr Johnson and mrsunak at that period of
time but if you're looking back at the
one thing that I think they could have
swung out I think British thought was
collateral damage stuck between a rock
and a hard place between the restaurants
the Rivalry between 10 and 11. yes the
concern I think some people within
government and many I imagine in the
public have is just that
you were asking for quite a lot of
public money so taxpayers money
and there are concerns that not all of
that money would have been spent in as
disciplined away as they would have
liked do you think that's fair there was
no misappropriation of fun because not a
single penny was spent on a private jet
100 000 went to a as you say a mansion
well it was a large house and if you
look at the cost of renting a hotel room
for that many people during that period
of time it was far more economical to
rent a house the fact that it happened
to have a pool that wasn't working for
18 months by the way it has nothing to
do with it a government spokesperson
said taxpayer money must always be used
responsibly which is why full due
diligence was undertaken before a final
Grant offer was made but the allegations
come as another car firm Citroen owner
stalantis warns it may shut its plants
down here because of a lack of battery
manufacturing and post-brexit trading
Arrangements speaking at an event today
the chancellor said watch this space but
without these factories the fate of
Britain's car industry is increasingly
under question at Conway Sky News
now for years experts and governments
have warned that it is crucial that
global temperatures don't rise by more
than 1.5 degrees now scientists say that
could be reached by 2027 already the
impacts of this rise in temperature can
be felt in weather events around the
world at least eight people have died in
Italy because of heavy rain and flooding
and organizers have canceled this week's
Italian Grand Prix for safety reasons
Sky's climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
reports
the Coast Guard rescuing stranded
residents in Northern Italy
a region coping with deadly and
destructive floods
families and small children trapped by
Rising Waters following days of heavy
rain the situation is so dangerous that
formula one has canceled the Grand Prix
in imela
scientists say extreme events like
flooding and the ongoing droughts in
Spain and France are made more frequent
and severe by climate change it comes as
the World Meteorological association
warns for the first time that it's now
more likely than not that global
temperatures will rise Beyond 1.5
degrees Celsius in the next five years
it's almost certain they say that in the
same time period we will experience the
hottest year ever the most dramatic
senses we expect to happen a cc in the
Arctic where we have already seen more
than double the global warming taking
place and during the coming five years
the estimation is that that the Arctic
temperatures would be three times the
global averages there are two reasons
for these predictions the first is that
even though we're already at 1.2 degrees
of warming carbon emissions keep Rising
you can see them here and therefore so
does the Heat last year for example was
the fifth warmest on record the other
issue is the likely return of a weather
phenomenon known as El Nino which tends
to push warm water up to the surface of
the Pacific Ocean further heating the
planet
the only way to solve the problem
researchers say is to sharply reduce
emissions for every year we continue
increasing the amount of greenhouse
gases we emit that's one year lost every
turn of greenhouse gases matters in
terms of how bad the extremes are and
how you know how
different the climate will be going
Beyond 1.5 maybe only temporary this
time but this is a hugely significant
moment a critical threshold a common
goal agreed by the International
Community now in real Jeopardy Hannah
Thomas Peter Sky News
now you might remember that yesterday we
brought you the story of the parents
unable to afford the soaring prices of
baby formula who say that they have been
driven to stealing it and looking for
sometimes even dangerous Alternatives
Sky News has now spoken to one of the
leading brands in the UK kendamill who
acknowledged the industry were not doing
enough to help struggling families and
now campaigners and one mother are
calling for the government to step in
Sky's National correspondent Tom
Parmenter has the story
the price Rises have hit hard
some families cannot afford to feed
their babies safely so they're watering
down bottles switching to cow's milk too
early stealing from shops or buying
second-hand tubs online
Kerry's boy Finley is still bottle fed
she's so Furious about what's happening
to families that she's petitioning the
government for change you feel
uncomfortable even walking down the baby
aisle and looking at the baby milk
because the staff instantly think oh
they're going to Nick that is that
you're treated as a criminal
just because you want to go and buy baby
milk just to help like lower the costs
or provide vouchers for those that work
hard for a living
all of the manufacturers say their
production costs have risen sharply we
went to the only formula milk factory in
Britain kendamill based in Cumbria while
they've raised their prices they
acknowledge their industry needs to do
more for families it's been toughest on
parents it's devastating to see but it
is the result of consistent cost price
inflation led by the multinational
conglomerates that control this Market
how much responsibility should the
industry as a whole take for the
positions that British families are
finding themselves in at the moment we
can't ignore the macroeconomic shocks
that we've had where we would like more
transparency is about the enormous price
discrepancies between very similar baby
formulas on the market do you believe
them the multinationals when they say
that they are doing absolutely
everything they can on behalf of
families
to keep those costs to a minimum
I mean it's
I don't think that they are pricing
those products as cheap as they could
price them for families Danon who make
aptamil and Cowan gate so they are
freezing the cost of bigger value packs
Nestle who made the SMA Brands say
they're open to discussing with
government what more they can do
the MP charged with investigating infant
feeding is horrified by what's happening
and is demanding a Government Review I
mean the net effect is a children
growing up I'm with you know
developmental issues because they
haven't had the proper nutrition that
they've needed as babies and that's
really quick I think that's the kind of
thing that you see in countries where
there has been you know famine or
malnutrition or war that should not be
happening in the United Kingdom in 2023.
I think it's important to see if the
government could do something around a
ceiling on the coast of infant formula
is a price cap realistic in what is a
commercial Market well the government
allowed this to be a commercial market
and there are times in the past where
the government have set limits on and
the prices of things there's no reason
why one should cost 10 pounds and one
should cost 15 pounds the UK government
continues to say that it is helping with
the cost of living but because feeding
never stops parents who are in this
struggle can't afford to wait for
something to change
Tom Parmenter Sky News
well as the government is facing calls
to help with people who are struggling
with the cost of living here the prime
minister is on his way to Japan for the
G7 meeting of world leaders to talk
about the global economy Ukraine and how
to tackle immigration our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates joins us
this evening from Downing Street evening
to you Assam let's talk about that
latter point that issue of immigration
because the prime minister is under
increasing pressure isn't he over the
targets that his own government has set
that's right Sam now you'll know that
most of this year we've been talking
about illegal migration stop the boats
but just the this week it's exploded as
an issue when it comes to Legal
migration there's a cabinet Rao broadly
speaking you've got Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor one side wanting to let more
people into work so well Abraham and the
Home Secretary wanted to keep those
numbers low and so it's against that
backdrop that Rishi sunak who's on his
way to the G7 in Japan faced really
quite uncomfortable questions he was
asked whether or not he still stood by
the promise that Boris Johnson his
predecessor made in the 2019 Manifesto
that he'd keep net migration figures
lower than the number at that point
which is about 260
000 and pretty soon that just said well
I've inherited some numbers and that was
pretty much it I think we could take
broadly speaking that as being him
sidestepping the question in other words
the answer that question is no he
doesn't think he's going to to hit that
Target now in some ways that response is
somewhat academic because in the next
few days Ministry ministers are
expecting net migration of not 250
thousand but something more like 750 000
that targets be blown out of the water
no way they're going to meet it but I
think also it speaks to a bigger truth
Sam which is that all this year Richie
sudak has been trying to set his own
metrics his own ways of judging his
government growing the economy stopping
the boat slashing inflation uh keeping
down the NHS waiting list and so on he
wants us to judge him on that but we are
totally within our rights to judge him
on the 2019 election Manifesto that he
stood on alongside Boris Johnson those
were the promises made to the public
when the public last went uh to the
polls and all of those questions in that
Manifesto are much much harder for him
to answer there'll be a lot more
sidestepping of those questions to come
I suspect
all right Sam thank you
now plans to scrap no fault evictions in
England have been unveiled today that's
as part of a long promised shake-up of
the rental market it's uh and assume
that it that impacts millions of people
at one time or another so there's no
surprise that there has been a lot of
reaction to that announcement but
although there is some praise for the
bill which has been called a huge
opportunity there are concerns that it
will push landlords out of the market as
our political correspondent Liz Bates
reports
for England's 11 million renters life
can be difficult I've been forced to
move three times since the start of the
pandemic through a combination of
no-fault evictions so like section 21s
and rent Rises now a change in the law
is coming that the government size will
help people like Jasmine by ending no
fault evictions I feel like more needs
to be done I feel like the bill doesn't
go far enough I say that because
um the way that I've been forced out
each time is it may have come with a
section 21 notice but in the end you
know uh I've been advised there's no
point in fighting your section 21 notice
if you can't afford to pay the rent
increase housing secretary Michael Gove
has insisted he is on the side of
renters and the plans will give more
powers to people like Belinda who says
her landlord has repeatedly refused to
fix mold and leaks and threatened her
with eviction the good news is that even
at a time when people are facing real
pressure on their household budgets that
rents in the private rented sector have
risen less than inflation and of course
in this legislation we affirm that rents
can only rise once a year and if rents
are thought to be unfair there's an
ombudsman now that we're creating
the bill will also give landlords new
powers to evict tenants that are
anti-social or behind on their rent it
will bring in new standards that Force
landlords to keep their properties safe
and well maintained and it will end
blanket bans on people on benefits or
with children
but some critics including conservative
MPS say it will drive landlords out of
the sector he was given to keys and
there's one two three four five six
seven front door keys Lisa has
experienced a problem tenant and has
used a no-fault eviction when he didn't
pay his rent I issued the section 21.
and which I'm very glad I did but he
didn't go out on the date he was he
lived there rent free for six months but
when she found out this law change was
coming she felt she had no choice but to
sell
it really does force your hand and I
decided to sell and I'm pretty sure
there's going to be quite a few
landlords doing the same thing and
selling
housing campaigners have called the
legislation a huge opportunity but with
house building targets scrapped and
Rising interest rates will it be enough
to fix the crumbling foundations of
Britain's rental market Liz Bates Sky
News North London
now a senior metropolitan police officer
has denied the force was under political
pressure to stop all anti-monarchy
protesters at the coronation temporary
assistant commissioner Matt twist
appeared before MPS this morning that
was following criticism of the way
officers handled demonstrations our
crime correspondent Martin brunt reports
protesting
testing the anti-monarchists were
planning disruption in their van they
found luggage straps and locks for
carrying heavy placards said the
protesters
the leader Graham Smith said months of
liaising with police on the day counted
for nothing immediately we were
surrounded by large numbers of tactical
support group officers who were not in
remotely friendly or helpful mindset we
never had any intention of doing
anything which even came close to
Falling outside of the law and the claim
that they had intelligence could not
possibly be true either they are being
dishonest or they are
making a very serious error
come on
the MP session was interrupted briefly
perhaps to little surprise by a
protester to be clear they would just
stop oil protesters who tried to
undermine the Activities Committee with
our Witnesses today
three days before the coronation
Parliament had given police tough new
powers to search and arrest to prevent
public protests turning into disruption
had the police overreacted I felt under
no pressure politically I felt pressure
to deliver a safe and secure operation
but that was because of the fact it was
a once in a lifetime event for so many
people and we are continually balancing
the rights of those who seek to protest
with those who are impacted by it
the officer said police action had to be
seen in context late intelligence had
warned of paint sprayers Invaders along
the Route and rape alarms to scare
horses
a volunteer handing out rape alarms was
arrested with colleagues we did the best
that we can
We complain who we were
I'm a bit speech
beating her that account
of what happened to you your colleagues
the day 52 protesters were arrested
there was tension and rival chanting but
no disruption to the coronation because
we're lowering lowering the threshold of
what isn't allowed in our society and to
disruptive it's going to lead to lots
more police involvement it's going to be
a lot more encounters with the police
but that is undoubtedly in my view going
to radicalize groups of protesters
the evidence gathered by MPS is expected
to be considered in their report this
summer on policing priorities Marty
brunt Sky News Westminster
the Armed Forces Minister has refused to
rule out defense spending cuts ahead of
the publication of a review Into the
UK's defense capabilities expected next
month James EP was speaking to Sky
news's Sophie rich
the world has become ever more insecure
and ever more unstable and so we need to
make sure that we are gearing ourselves
against all of those threats I mean I
I'm not ruling
cuts out I'm not ruling increases out
Brentford Striker Ivan Tony has been
suspended from all football for eight
months and fined 50 000 pounds that's
after breaking fa betting rules the
England International admitted 232
breaches between February 2017 and
January 2021 the sanctions mean that the
27 year old won't be available to play
again until January next year although
he will be allowed to return to training
this September